Let's go now to our guest CZ, the
founder of Binance. CZ, thank you so
much for coming on Galaxy Brands. I want
[music] to ask about Hyperlid.
>> So, we have some interesting history
with Hyperlid that I didn't know about.
We force everyone to use Bitcoin. That
itself is actually not decentralization.
>> That's authoritarianism.
>> Crypto, no matter what it does, it
doesn't have the power to extinguish our
civilization. But AI has [music] the
power to extinguish.
>> Are you worried about quantum as a
threat to Bitcoin?
>> No, I'm actually not worried about it at
all. I mean, crypto is not going away.
Crypto is going to be a big industry.
Okay. Well, yeah, we can regulate the
industry by killing it,
>> right?
>> Um, that's not regulating. That's just
killing.
>> Welcome to Galaxy Brains.
>> An infinite amount of cash cash. I'm
your host, Alex. The US banking system
is sound and resilient. Bitcoin made a
new alltime high.
>> If you're not long, if you're not long,
you're short.
>> Satashi is going to come on there, laugh
hysterically, go quiet. Oh, Bitcoin's
going to be erased. Bitcoin. Bitcoin is
the best crypto ever. Bitcoin is going
to zero.
Welcome back to Galaxy Brains. As
always, I'm your host, Alex Thorne, head
of firmwide research at Galaxy.
Bitcoin's not zero. We have a great
episode for you this week. CZ, the
founder of Binance, is our guest. He
joins me in the studio here in New York
to talk about a range of topics with his
vast experience in crypto. What does he
think about the current market cycle?
What is the draw down? How long will it
last? And has Bitcoin bottomed? And a
range of other fascinating topics. We'll
get CZ's thoughts on AI, what he's
investing in personally today in which
space is, what the future of the great
convergence between Tradfi and crypto
is, and much more. BIM Net is off this
week, and before we get to the interview
with CZ, I need to remind you to please
refer to the link to disclaimer in the
podcast notes. And note that none of the
information in this podcast constitutes
investment advice or an offer,
recommendation, or solicitation by
Galaxy or any of its affiliates to buy
or sell any securities. Let's hop into
it with CZ. Let's go now to our guest,
CZ, the founder of Binance. CZ, thank
you so much for coming on Galaxy Brands.
>> Well, thank you for having me, Alex.
>> Um, and thank you for coming to our
office here in New York. Um, I want to
start by asking you about this current
market cycle. Um, I had done some math
and it turns out it really is the
four-year cycle, like almost to the day.
Yep.
>> Which is crazy.
>> Um, you know, we're a long way off, got
the block here, we're a long way off the
all-time high of 125K or so. Um, is this
a normal like cycle? Do you think it'll
look different? What's your sense of
where we are in the Bitcoin wave of
price?
>> So, yeah, I think the four-year cycle is
actually pretty accurate. Um, so, um, I
think it's a pretty normal cycle. Um,
you know, you retraced about 50%. Um, I
think like we've seen worse. We've seen
like 80% retracements in previous
cycles.
>> Yeah. And if you look at the current low
um four years ago u I was just talking
with somebody else earlier today 2022
around this time was probably the uh US
Luna crash
>> um that didn't hit the bottom the um FTX
crash later on in November hit the
bottom was like 16k
>> so we're still like what four five times
higher yeah so if you compare the lows
there still 5x increase u in the four
years so um u yeah so I think it's it's
a normal cycle but every cycle is higher
so over a long term. No, I'm a very
long-term. I'm not going to exit.
There's no exit in crypto for [laughter]
me. So, uh um yeah. So, you know, I
think it's a just a normal cycle. Yeah.
>> Do you think that um what looks about
the cycle, not necessarily the shape and
pattern, but what is true now that
stands out to you in this Bitcoin market
that wasn't true in 22 or 2018
>> in your mind? I mean, I know there's a
lot, but like what's you know?
>> Oh, yeah. the there's so much more de
positive devel development now um today
versus four years ago today you have the
world's most powerful country supporting
crypto uh whereas four years ago that
was the total opposite uh there were war
on crypto by the by the US government uh
here so um where we sit now um so and
also because of the US stance on cryptos
changed 180 degrees every other country
is following right so now US leads in
the crypto regulatory uh frameworks and
also the discussions etc. Um just that
just that alone is hugely different and
we're seeing like you know very strong
institutional adoption. Black Rockck um
um all the ETFs BNB ETF got list got
listed um last week and then um um just
so much more institutional participation
that wasn't there um um four years ago.
Um and the life cycle was mostly like
you know because the the previous SEC
was suing everybody in crypto right so
there was no utility uh tokens being
developed everyone went to the memecoin
space but now we're seeing actually a
lot more uh real development so now
there's more developers coming back to
the US many of them left the US during
the during the during the last
administration because they were just so
hostile.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and now we're seeing we're seeing a
lot more development now. So um there's
more stable coins being issued in every
country. Um there's more um what we call
real world assets. There's now you can
buy SPEX uh preIPO uh token tokens on I
guess on Binance.
>> Yeah.
>> Um so and many other exchanges too. So
um yeah, so a lot more is happening. Um
and I'm really excited. So even though
we're talking about the cycles, the
cycles don't end at the same place. Each
cycle so much higher than the than the
last one.
>> Yeah. Is that I I tend to think of that
you you mentioned the like yearly low or
the cycle low as a floor that's been
rising. I tend to think of that when
people say, "Oh, no. Bitcoin hasn't
acted as a digital gold." And I'm sort
of like, "No, no, it that's that is the
digital gold growing on below and it's
growing and then, you know, the
speculators come in and move it all
around on top." And it does seem like
that,
>> you know, we're at 60K. Um, that that
floor rising is the long-term people
using it as a as a digital gold-like
asset.
>> I think Bitcoin only reached 60k what,
two years ago? Uh so like you know if we
say like two four years ago if we say we
said Bitcoin can hit 50.
>> Well in 21 I think it reached.
>> Oh actually that's true. In 21 it
reached that
>> but I mean that
>> but that's alltime high
>> right. That's right now it's like we've
we're we're [laughter] bottom. Well are
we bottoming? Do you think where would
you have to guess the bottom would be
here in this cycle?
>> I'm never accurate on this and I I hate
to make predictions but uh the previous
high are usually the future support. So
like where 60,000 was like the previous
all-time high uh in like four or five
years ago u now we feel it's very low.
Uh so typically uh those support uh psy
and there's there psychological and also
um technical uh reasons for it. People
who bought uh at 60,000 when it when the
price come back to 60,000 they may they
might cash out. The people who uh but
but now people who bought at 60,000 they
will not sell now right. So uh you went
to 120k they come down. So they will
just buy more.
>> Yeah. It's like a stepped up cost basis.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So the in technical analysis
the previous highs always becomes the
next low support. So u uh there's quite
a lot of uh disc um well there's quite a
lot of um theories behind that. I don't
know if they're true or not. Uh I'm not
a great technical analyst u but I think
you know uh it feels like that. Yeah.
>> All right. And and we'll move on beyond
the cycle talk. One more I think that's
so different looking between this
all-time high to current draw down and
this cycle versus certainly 2022 one and
two those prior you know blowoff tops
and then bare markets were either
characterized by or even perhaps caused
by sort of major marquee blowups in the
crypto industry um often about the you
know an unhealthy search for yield or
yield often at the core of that story.
Um, are there dead bodies that you think
still that haven't floated to the
because we haven't really heard about
this really yet since the October of
last year. Are there dead bodies we
don't know about you think in your mind
that haven't floated to the surface?
That's a very interesting question
actually. I was curious about that. Um,
even like maybe 6 months ago uh but
during the last 6 months there hasn't
been anybody saying like they're going
bankrupt etc. So I think the industry
got better at uh at controlling um uh
leverage or boring. Uh so um I think
there were there was there were a few
shocks uh in the in the system and um
but no one no one went no one went
bankrupt etc. So knock on wood I
>> yeah none of the platforms really that I
that I've seen not like the you know the
lending companies and exchanges like
FTX. Um, is there dangerous leverage in
the system now this time that's unique
say from treasury companies or onchain
per something that you worry about
>> based on my exposure to the industry
like based on what I know which is a
small subset of the of what what the
industry maybe people think I know
everything but I only know a very small
subset um and uh I don't I actually
don't see a lot of hugely leveraged uh
products right now um so I think there
were some stable coins which were giving
high yields they were like they were
loop uh borrowing etc But overall those
the size of those things are relatively
small to the industry size now. So uh I
don't see any huge things with with a
lot of leverage today. Yeah. So
hopefully that should be good that that
that's a very good thing actually.
>> Uh all right let's move on a little bit.
Let's talk about Wall Street and the
what we call the great convergence
between tradi and crypto.
>> It's definitely happening right. Crypto
is building tokenized securities real
world assets things like that. Tradfi is
integrating cryptos or building on new
blockchains. Absolutely.
>> Um assuming they do eventually reach a
stasis of integration. Um where do you
think the line between decentralization
and centralization will have landed?
Will they will Treadfi make crypto more
centralized or will crypto make TRDFI
more decentralized?
>> Uh I think both will happen. U as you
said we're seeing that convergence
already. And also in theory there
shouldn't be a convergence like crypto
is not a separate industry. Crypto is
just a new technology, new tool that
makes uh financial transactions uh that
facilitates financial transactions in a
higher speed, lower cost, more
transparent way, etc. So, it's just a
new tool. Um this is like you know um uh
there's no internet company, right? So
there are like internet infrastructure
companies like Cisco whatever, right?
right? Uh you don't make like um for
like know for bookstore you can you can
you can create an online version of it
and know you can grow big it doesn't
have to be a pure e-commerce company per
se right so um now traditional what we
call traditional financial companies
they can use blockchains it's open to
anyone they can use this new technology
they can use the bitcoin blockchain they
can develop their own blockchains they
can there's a variety of different
technologies all of most of all of them
are like most of them are open source
>> so anybody can adopt adopt this
technology. And then for the crypto uh
companies, crypto guys um they can offer
services very similar to traditional
financial services. Now they can provide
loans, savings, um trade stocks now. So
um um uh remittances, payments, all of
those things uh crypto can do. And they
don't have to be limited to crypto.
They're now integrating stable coins.
They have fiat fiat channels. They
handle like sort of fiat currencies as
well. So um they shouldn't be this
division. there should just be one. This
should just be the it's it's just the
financial industry. It's the fintech
industry. Um and now it's just more
global. Um it's just with this new
blockchain is faster, cheaper. U many of
the crypto guys don't do a lot of the
traditional what the trai the structure
is different. So um so I think we're
definitely going to see that well we're
definitely going to see that convergence
and um there shouldn't be a convergence
per se. It just be one industry. Uh so I
think that's good to see on the
decentralization versus centralization
part. Yes. Any any platform any company
in in in the industry is part is a part
is part of a centralization. Even any
team any any project that has more than
one person is centralization. Yeah.
>> Right. So the more but you know humans
we have network effects. We like to we
have we we we usually work in a team. um
very few guys can work solo with AI that
might change um to some extent but no we
we need a team of people usually uh so
um and then but the technology is always
evolving to be more or more
decentralized so I think um both will
happen the centralization aspects of it
um and the decentraliz decentralization
of it so I think also many people sort
of have a binary view of centralization
versus decentralization in a
decentralized world anybody can work
together, right? So, you should
decentralized world should accommodate
centralized players.
>> Um the centralized players if they offer
really good services at a at a low cost,
very secure, then they will gather more
and more users. There's network effects.
Um and uh that causes small groups of
centralization. Of course, if um
monopolies have advantages and
disadvantages, we've seen that many in
history. Um so, uh yeah. So but
companies who abuse the monopoly power
usually uh lose their market u monopoly
over time. It may take a while but that
will happen and they just give new
entrance opportunities. So um so I think
yeah the the it's it's going to be
always coexist uh to some extent u but
I'm a strong proponent for
decentralization. Um so I think the
technology will continue to push forward
in the dec uh more and more tools will
become more and more decentralized. some
of the banks and card networks are now
building their own blockchains because I
think and you're totally right you know
you can build a business on top of a
decentralized platform but I think
they've been resistant to allowing their
assets to go on the decentralized
platforms
>> um so even some of them are building
semi-entralized blockchains
>> um some examples there was Mastercard
announced the new one MTN right circle
>> and you know without passing any like
some of these are more or less
decentralized than others but tether
Circle, Stripe are all building stable
coin focused blockchains. Got Canton now
which is from digital assets. So it's
like the
>> you know the next iteration of the sort
of classic permission blockchain.
>> Um you know is that
why aren't they building on BNB,
Ethereum, Solana and also should they?
Ah okay I think well in a decentralized
world if if you force everyone to build
on specific blockchain or everyone
anyone can build their own blockchain
that's what the decentralized ethos is
and then I think the more different
blockchains they are the better it is
actually for the consumers to to an
extent right sometimes cause consumer uh
confusion and uh liquidity segmentation
etc but by and large the more choices we
have the better um and and over time
like the consumers it will be clear
which which will uh which ones will have
usage
Um and uh uh it's also not clear that um
the majority of people just care about
only care about central
decentralization. I think most people
care about low cost, secure, easy to
ease of use um and those basic things.
Um and most people
>> like we're hardcore uh Bitcoiners and or
crypto guys. Yeah.
>> And um we talk about decentralization.
We understand the implications of that,
but most people just look at the
results, right? So they they just want
low cost, easy e ease of use and
security um and freedom. Um so if those
guys uh you know traditional uh large
financial players um if they de they
want to develop their own their own
proprietary blockchains um and they
somehow get people to use them then
kudos to them. But I think more and more
people is going to demand more freedom
because now there's this side with uh
the true sort of decentralized uh crypto
world that have uh much higher degree of
freedom and much lower cost etc. So it
this puts the pressure on them to become
that. Let's say look um if a few large
companies develop a sta uh their own
stable coin that's on the blockchain on
their own blockchain but you can't
transfer to to a guy across the world um
then they will limit the usage right so
I think people the the demand is there
we want we want we want to be able to
trans transact with anyone in the world
instantaneously at low cost um without
worrying about borders um all all of
this stuff of of course compliance is
important um so um yeah so uh it dep at
the end of the day it dep it's what the
consumers choose to use. Yeah,
>> I think that's a fair way of looking at
it. I I also personally think that like
a private permission blockchain, not
passing judgment on which what label
which of the specific ones I would label
that
>> um it feels a little bit like a like a
corporate internet
>> and like the public permissionless
general purpose blockchains are more
like the open internet. Yeah.
>> And so maybe there's a hub and spoke if
they still okay for some reason inside
their four walls they want it to be on
their chain but if they can bridge and
that's a knock on wood bridging is risky
these days but like if they can somehow
interconnect to the broader it's kind of
like the cosmos thesis yet again.
>> Yes. So you you have many you have many
like what do we call it like hubs and
>> spokes and hubs. Spokes and hubs right.
So it's totally possible like look look
and many countries they're not com
they're not they're not totally
comfortable with like a purely open
blockchain they they all they all want
their own national blockchain
>> is that true
>> yeah so like with many of my discussions
with different country leaders they all
want like a national blockchain right
>> so interesting
>> u but it's just the human psychology
takes them time to say look we're going
to let go control of money or we're
going to let go control of um the
financial sector in our country um so um
you know so that might be a stepping
stone u and over time you will evolve of
and also it's like for a large country
like say for the USA if all of Wall
Street somehow uses one or two
blockchains and that's kind of
proprietary all the big players that's
that's this you still see trillions of
dollars moving through those networks
and know that's fine um the retail guys
may not use may be cut out from that
even but that's fine as long as you know
a corporate internet
>> as long as know there's enough activity
on there you know that's fine like that
that's that that serves it purpose
>> so to each their own basically and we'll
see how it shakes out I guess.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I guess especially for
when we when we advocating
decentralization
um decentralization is different from
like everyone have to use a open-source
single blockchain that's every if we
force everyone to use Bitcoin that
itself is actually not decentralization.
>> Yeah, that's authoritarianism [laughter]
basically. Yeah, that's right.
>> So it's a bit counterintuitive. Yeah,
>> that's that's a good point. Um let's
move on to some other topics. Uh Binance
built the modern perpetual swap. Um now
of course PERPS are and not then too but
even more so now they're sort of key
financial instrument today in crypto and
have been um you know even before
Binance obviously BitMEX had sort of the
one of the first per exchange I saying
like the per that Binance offers now are
the pers that people use
>> today so they modernized it but
separately though as long as you know
back into 201617 when Arthur Hayes had
pers on BIMx and later um these have and
a very important and highly efficient
and and for those who know how to use
them well, a great financial instrument.
Now, it looks like we're going to get
per so legalization of crypto pers in
the US. So, you're going to see maybe
the big futures, you know, CME and SIBO
probably and whatever else CFTC licensed
entities trading cryptos, but also
perhaps stocks, per stocks.
>> Yeah. Y
>> um when they arrive officially in the US
or any major market, what happens to
like the um like you know quote unquote
offshore crypto exchange leading the per
world because that's been the case even
today. Hyperlid also as an example of
that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. So there's quite a
lot of interesting implications there.
Um just Yeah. I think you you a long
question.
>> Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. That's quite
there's quite a few things there. I
think um um uh well first of all per
perpetual futures was not invented in
crypto right uh it was exist exists in
traditional finance
>> I think was was [clears throat] it the
first implementation though
>> a haste did the first implementation in
2014 uh in crypto at BitMax right and
then Binance was late Binance like only
started offering them in 2019 uh so five
years later um and there was a few
others offering different v varieties of
u uh not maybe not per futures but
delivery futures every Friday you have
to like you know um do a settlement a
rollover um so there was different
variations Binance started offering them
but Binance had the largest user base so
now know it's got the by far the best
liquidity and and the and the best
volume and also the best prices lowest
slippage etc um and now with u CME uh
this trai like traditional giant uh
futures exchanges um listing futures now
um I think it's it's good because um
they serve a market that we never serve
well that Binance never served, right?
So, um, uh, Binance never served those
instit in institutions in the US. Uh,
well, Binance doesn't Binance Global
doesn't serve any US.
Um, and, um, uh, and which one will get
bigger? That's actually le a less
important question, at least to me
personally. As long as we have more
people trading crypto, it is better.
most likely if uh CME or Seabbot or
whoever else in in the US the uh they
can get all the institutions trading um
crypto futures uh and that's more
liquidity that there will be guys who
can trade on both platforms that will
bridge liquidity there will be more
liquidity for crypto trading and that
and I think that's really really good.
So uh I'm less concerned about like know
who has to be bigger than the other. Uh
I think uh the more people uh have
access to crypto uh per trading the
better liquidity is and the the liquid
liquid better liquidity is actually the
best protection for consumers. When when
there's good liquidity you see much less
crashes etc. Yeah. And much less
liquidations et um so just better
protection. And then um you throw the
last part which is well now the crypto
exchanges are trading like stock futures
um and there's many other things that we
they're not trading yet. uh even the the
unstructured products that's not traded
today could potentially be structured
and enough to be traded on the
blockchain and FX can trading I I
predict will will move to the
blockchain.
>> Yeah.
>> Um every country will eventually have
their own stable coins and then uh those
will be available to be trading onchain
247. Um and I think the FX price
discovery might actually happen on
onchain because it's much more
transparent, much easier to see and much
more continuous. So I think all of those
things will happen. Will that have a
negative impact in traditional like you
know stocks stock markets? I think so.
But again the the the at least for
Binance uh ecosystem for what I can see
the uh the the the users are very
separate right. So uh today like you
know you live the guys in who live in
New York and in this country have well
we can buy stock whatever you want but
most other people outside of the country
uh cannot buy it's not that easy for
them to buy US stocks. Some of them,
some of them can, but it's actually a
very small number percentage- wise in
the population. Which country don't want
the stocks to be available to everyone
in the world, right? So like look, if
you list SpaceX, why don't you want
everyone in the world to buy the stock,
right? Which company wouldn't want that?
Which stock exchange wouldn't want that?
Which country wouldn't want everybody in
the world to buy your government bond,
right? Why would you prevent other
people from buying your government bond?
Uh so um and look if one country buys a
lot of your government bond that's
actually the easiest reason for you guys
not to have a conflict [laughter] right
so so you guys have to negotiate on
trade and not attack each other so um uh
so uh so I think the world is becoming a
smaller place uh even though even with
all the geopolitical tension etc I think
the world is becoming a small place um
and also I think uh crypto exchanges uh
providing access for people who are not
in that country to buy your stock it
doesn't hurt the current stock exchanges
is in the country. Um it actually helps
it uh it's better liquidity, better
demand, etc. So yeah, that's my view.
>> Okay. I I like your point about uh
increasing access to stocks being one of
the key benefits to tokenizing stocks.
>> Um and I did look into this also. I was
surprised to find it. It's actually cost
prohibitive for many people to buy
stocks. Here we can, you know, can buy
them on I think you can buy them right
in Cash App or like in Venmo. Uh but I
mean it's really quite easy. But, you
know, in some countries I've heard, uh,
you know, to even be able to open an
account that can trade a US ADR there or
has access to a, I don't know,
corresponding broker that can place the
trade here has like really high
minimums, for example. You know, $5,000,
which, you know, most of the world can't
actually put up as a minimum. Yeah.
>> Um, yeah.
>> And each trade is like two to 5%.
>> Right.
>> Right. So, how many times can you trade?
So, um, uh, and also like and also just
many parts you just don't have access.
Doesn't matter how much premium you want
to pay.
>> Just can't get it in at all.
>> Just just you just kind of get access.
>> Um I want to ask about Hyperlid. It's
one of the few actually positive coins
in return this year here to date. Um but
also obviously a big and growing uh
platform. It sits somewhere I would say
more decentralized than Binance although
less decentralized than like unis swap
as an example. Somewhere in the middle.
Um have you met Jeff? What are your
thoughts on hyperlquid you know just
generally?
>> Sure. Sure. Um, so we have some
interesting history with Hyperlid that
that I didn't know about with Jeff
specifically. Uh, I never met him in
person. Um, he was actually in one of
the earliest u, uh, easy labs incubation
seasons,
>> right?
>> Uh, so I assume he's a very smart young
kid. Um, and he obviously very capable.
>> Um, so uh, so this, you know, some long
history there and also I think the
hyperlquid invention is actually
awesome. Um, he proved a new uh, market
niche um, that wasn't there. Well, that
was not proven by other people before.
So, he created something new. Uh, which
is which is very interesting. Um, and
apparently he has a very small team. Um,
and um uh I'm sure you know uh uh those
that team is very capable. Um they
occupy a niche that Binance the exchange
cannot compete. Um they you know they
they don't have KYC. Um they claim
they're decentralized. Um again I'm not
going to comment on another project. um
uh based on the technology we see there
they have a lot of control um it's a
small team that controls the platform um
so whether that's decent well they they
use a smart contract for deposit
withdrawals that that claim that's
that's decentralized um I'm not going to
get into the definition of it that's not
my place so but they serve a niche where
look in the in the US if you have a VPN
you can use it right so everybody knows
that um so yeah uh but they they they no
they have pretty decent volumes Um and
they are able to service many users that
Binance cannot serve. Uh which I again
it's not in my my place to comment
whether that's good or not. Um so uh but
they they they have some technology
innovation that I think is is quite
good. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um and well I mean just since you
raised it too the you know the history
of no KYC crypto exchange is filled with
people getting in trouble for that. Like
should they be Yeah. Should they be
worried?
>> I would never do what they do. uh given
what I've experienced in my life. Um but
I'm not a legal person. I cannot give
other people people advice. Um I no um
again I think I assume they have good
lawyers. Um they're making a lot of
money. Um so I assume they're they check
they handle they're big boys. They
handle themselves.
>> That's a fair answer. Um so not per
markets. I think one of the breakout
sort of new segments of it's not
necessar it's not really crypto although
poly market the I think the I think
they're the largest
>> um or at least the largest independent
one
>> um is built on crypto um
>> what are your thoughts on prediction
market you know a lot of jurisdictions
are both inside the US certain US states
are mad then different countries are
either grappling with them or trying to
regulate them or mad about them
>> um but also just they appear to have a
fair amount of utility uh especially in
certain circumstances where you would
have to trade a proxy to an event rather
than the event itself
>> um either on the regulation or just on
the product the concept how do you think
about prediction markets now
>> I also think that's a very clever or
good invention well that's not a new
invention prediction markets have been
around for a while event futures
prediction markets
>> I remember trading on one called in
trade I think that was based out of the
UK one time presidential elections like
in 2008 I could trade there
>> yeah they they come and goal, right? So,
as as you said, they they that feels a
little bit like betting, right? You're
betting on you're like going to kind of
predict an outcome of an event.
>> Uh so, uh again, I'm not a lawyer. Uh
there's many I I assume there's many
different reg uh different regulations
different places about this particular
uh u uh industry. Um but it does feel
like um at least in um in my when I
listen to talks by like for example the
CFTC chairman Michael Silic he's no in
multiple talk he's he's quite he's quite
supportive of it at least in tone I I
don't know I don't know the legal
definitions how they define it but at
least in tone he know he's very
supportive uh multiple people are
multiple important people in the US
agencies are supportive
>> I personally think it's is a great thing
um I think anything that uh allows
people to uh discover discover price
price discovery liquidity uh is good um
uh there are many implications for this
in real world implications whether it's
uh uh funding to predict the weather
better um to uh you know predictions are
important in our lives yeah we want to
be able to predict things better um so
uh where there's real money on on the
line um you know uh I think the money
the prediction markets are much more
accurate than any every other prediction
because any anybody who have good
predictions will be in in those markets
>> so Um there's some real real really
really interesting implications for it.
Um so I am a you know I I founded one of
the exchanges. Uh so I like to see any
tool that provides price discovery and
liquidity. So I think it's great. Um and
also it's also great that u uh I believe
poly market koshi they all have licenses
in the US and so this no this means that
I didn't know that you you mentioned
that states may some states may not like
it etc. Yeah, because uh the reason
though is because they have prediction
market one the sort of the hook for them
is that they have prediction markets on
sports outcomes
>> which is historically considered sports
gambling which is a highly regulated
state-by-state level activity
historically in the US that's why
they're upset.
>> Okay. So that's just the state versus
federal
>> because you're right you are right the
CFTC is
>> has taken a strong stance legally as
well. They've joined cases to defend
cryp uh prediction market firms against
state. They've joined them or they
submitted amicus briefs in support of
the prediction markets
>> and they're uh they they're releasing
new a new rulemaking framework okay for
prediction markets which the existence
of alone is
>> um supportive. So it is yeah they are
supportive and and also um the CFTC is
very clearly asserting its federal
primacy over the states as it relates to
prediction markets. So there is an
interesting intergovernmental okay sort
of thing here but but yes you were right
they are supportive. Okay, I actually
didn't know those details. Yeah, like I
always stay away from politics, right?
So any any sort of jurisdiction fights,
I stay away. But I think uh for
consumers uh as an industry globally for
crypto um it's a good thing. Uh and u uh
uh but as with any new technology, new
platform, uh as long as they do it well,
you'll be really good. Um there are
always ways to do badly. But I think the
larger players today do really well. And
I think there's quite a lot of new
upcoming u prediction markets as well.
like that's probably like [laughter] 100
a thousand plus prediction market
projects in the crypto space. So I hope
all of them will will execute it
responsibly. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um let's talk about something you
mentioned earlier um about you know many
more blockchains, many more consumer
choice being you know good and and of
course there are many and there probably
will be more. most activity is like in
crypto today is probably I don't want to
say centralized it's sort of um coalesed
around like Ethereum Solana BNB Tron
>> that's maybe you know probably falls off
after that but you know a few others
>> um
>> BNB has definitely consolidated itself
into a top tier chain it's also a top
asset
>> um you know what's exciting about BNB
right now that we should be focusing on
or looking at
>> Sure as researchers but also just the
public.
>> Sure. Sure. So now I don't like I don't
run the exchange. I actually have a lot
more time to talk with developers in the
in the community. I'm actually really
excited about some of the new features
they're building uh on B&B chain. Um uh
they so uh one of my recommendations to
the developers is like no don't do big
upgrades during bull markets but in bare
markets market is quieter you you you
make a big upgrade. So I I actually
advise this to every blockchain not not
just the B&B uh blockchain developers.
Um so now they're working on a next
version uh which is uh much faster which
is much cheaper uh more uh privacy
controls for for users. Um there's quite
a long list of features that when I saw
it I was like so I'm not a very
imaginative guy actually. I don't I
don't I don't drive this things. U but
when I saw their like when I talked to
them when I saw the list of features
that they're building I was like wow
you're going to get all of this in one
version.
>> Uh so so they're building it. Do they
have a name for this forthcoming upgrade
yet that we should
>> I don't know the name actually. I think
they have a code name but I forgot.
>> Well, we'll check it and I'll throw it
in the show notes.
>> Sure. Sure. No, I I forgot. Um, but I
talked to the developers like, you know,
but I don't run it, right? So, this is
this is this is their drive. Um, yeah.
So, uh,
>> is that is that to compete a little bit
like Solana, you know, broke onto the
scene, I guess, years ago at this point
by being faster and cheaper than
Ethereum? You know, you've got like and
other differentiations. Um, privacy has
been a big topic these days as well.
like is that
>> is that for one just to make it better
or is it is there competi I don't know
how sort of semi or decentralized L1
developer teams think about big upgrades
like this?
>> Sure. Sure. Um I think um well no I I
think there's not a competition with a
specific chain. I think Salona came
around you know um four or five years
ago I guess maybe maybe even bit longer.
>> Um and then uh uh initially it was going
to be supported by FTX like know
SPF was all over it.
>> Yeah. Uh and then they suffered quite a
bit because of the FTF's crash, but it
was great to see their recovery. Yeah.
Uh so it shows the resilience of a
decentralized blockchain. Um Salona um
when B&B chain was first started, um
there was quite a lot of accusations on
B&B chain being overly centralized
because they have less nodes than
Ethereum, but Salona has much less
nodes. So there's a there's always a
balance of nodes versus performance,
right? The lesser nodes, the faster you
can the less time you need to
synchronize. I think Ethereum is still
like the holy what they want to be the
fully decentralized. So every upgrade is
really difficult for them. Yeah. So
there's there's a balance there
somewhere. Um I think uh B&B ch up to
like a I don't know. I can't remember. I
actually don't know. It's like 41 nodes
or 100 nodes. I actually don't know.
>> We'll look to and we'll throw that in
the as well. [laughter] Don't worry.
Don't worry.
>> Like how on technical
>> get a computer in here, Phineas. Look it
up.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So um uh and also but I think uh
Salona's rise and recovery wasn't so
much the decentralization versus non-
decentralization aspect of it. Uh it's
that they were very heavy into the meme
space. Uh they also marketed themselves
really well um in the in the US where
B&B chain was not marketing themselves
at all. Um they were also so they they
got they got a lot more US developers on
on the chain uh during the last
administration where B&B chain was
trying to stay out of the US or anything
related to B&B chain, Binance, myself
we're trying to just stay away as far
away as possible and also um uh during
the life cycle where you know the last
administration the last SEC was suing
every crypto project uh it's very hard
to launch a crypto project that has
utility and so that's why all the meme
coins were were were were pro
proliferating trading um and Salona
didn't have exchange associated with
them anymore after FDX went down. So
they just went like um they just went
they they they use the word pump and
dump a lot, right? So there's a there's
a platform called pump pump. Fun
>> in the B&B chain ecosystem. If there's a
if there's a platform called pump, uh
there will be like a lot of regulatory
increase, right? So like in the BMBB
chain because there's a there's a
Binance like a large exchange and B&B
chain even though it's a completely
separate blockchain is completely
independent but you we're kind of still
in the sort of closer ecosystem. And
we're much more scrutinized by
regulators. Anything that's called pump
in our in our like on the BMBB ecosystem
will get a lot more scrutiny. Yeah.
>> So the the chance all grown
indifferently um uh so but I think
that's good right. So um I think that's
actually that's actually very good for
the space. If you only have one ch in
the space um then regulator will
probably be shut down by now. Uh the
fact that we have multiple blockchains
is actually a good thing and they prol
they proliferate in different places at
different times and that actually helps
the entire industry to grow. So I think
I think that's really good. I think
Salona's recovery is fantastic is
actually phenomenal. Yeah.
>> Um Ethereum sort of community took a
path they were taking this path before
Salona but it sort of became urgent
which their own hub and spoke model
because that the layer 1 blockchain is
highly decentralized. So they promoted
this L2 thesis but then the L2s are
predominantly optimistic single
sequencer rollups today not
decentralized really and I don't think
any have reached whatever stage of I
think it's stage two of of actually
being decentralized. Um what do you
think about that thesis and I know
Vitalic has seemed to sort of say well
maybe we should be working on the L1
more again.
>> Yeah. Yeah. you know,
>> uh I did I did sense that shift in
Vitalik's tone and also um uh also yeah
I think was like also four or five years
ago where the Ethereum community was all
about L2s.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh and I think um in the last couple
years they kind of uh they kind of
reverse course and stopped
>> because now the biggest one by far is
base which is basically operated by one
company. It's not I mean there there are
some you know safety ways. It's not that
you you have an unilateral exit
capability. Yeah.
>> But you know the sequencer can order
transactions, charge arbitrary fees,
whatever.
>> Exactly. Exactly. So the L2s are not
very centralized, extremely centralized.
So now uh with the extreme community,
they want uh you want to promote fully
decentralization, but all the L2s are
super super centralized. And then um um
so uh and also the L2s don't but I don't
think that's the main reason. The I
think I believe the main reason is L2s
don't contribute to the L1's, right? So
they they only no they the L2s only need
to spend the Ethereum once like I don't
know uh with a batch, right? So they
they actually don't contribute to
>> I think we did the math and we found
that bass was paying more in licensing
fees to opt the optimism foundation to
use the tech than they are actually
paying in Ethereum L1 fees.
>> Oh, by far by far. It's probably by like
two or three magnitudes, right? So uh so
and then uh eventually they I think
Vitalic figured out that [laughter] the
L2s don't help the L1's and then
Ethereum went through a period of where
they had uh Vitalic has to deal with a
lot of pressure due to the price uh
performance of Ethereum and there was a
lot of jokes online which is unfair to
him to be honest. Um but I think that uh
all of those things combined uh made him
realize that well he still got to work
on the L1. So now he's shifted his focus
a bit which is no fairly normal for uh
know you you experiment you try
different things. Totally. Yeah. So, um,
so there's still like no, as you said,
like there's still pretty strong a few
strong L2s, but I think in the future
it's still L1. Like the it's to be
honest, it might be like, uh, what do
you call it? Um, a back and forth thing
for a while like know L1's will get
faster, but then the demand will will
come and then the L1's can't scale that
quickly and then there'll be they may
still be other L2 type of solutions in
the future. Again, they will be like
they may they may be back and forth. I
think this is a a decent option to
instead of building a whole new chain if
you're a big bank or something
>> do some kind of L2 on an existing chain
especially if the chain is natively
built for like safe bridging the way the
optimistic roll-ups are right they don't
they're not bridging back to the L1 they
integrate directly that could be an
interesting way for the hub and spoke to
which doesn't seem like what the
decentralized main
>> consumer base of Ethereum actually
wanted today it may have a place though
>> yeah but well L2's as as centralized as
they are, if after a batch is still
synchronized with the L1, um still
immutable.
>> That's right.
>> Right. So, um it's still like no, they
still like know it's still better than
like what uh where today a bank can just
change records.
>> You can change records from 10 years
ago.
>> Right. Because if I ask the L2 to you
know process a transfer from Alex to CZ
and it the sequencer refuses, I can just
replay that directly on the L1. So you
can um but that does get to this one
thing I you know this is what the L2
maximalists always say is that that
unilateral exit capability is like the
stop gap and it is but if the
transaction isn't a simple transfer and
it's a top up of a loan collateral some
kind of trade like that has real
implications even if you could get out
you know
>> you know what I mean like if I need to
top up liquidity or I need to
>> that's where it starts to actually
become problematic right like or
honestly even if it's just a trade
>> I actually didn't think that far
>> but it needs to be like right now and
even 1 minute late is like a problem
>> then having to go through that like
that's sort of what I
>> you know if the again if the sequencer
chooses to censor you on the L2
>> it's one thing I think about I think
about it a lot with tokenized securities
>> okay
>> we tokenize Galaxy stock on Solana
>> I think we would do other general
purposes too we just I started with one
>> um as an issuer sponsored security but
one thing I knew is that I just didn't
think the L2s were decentralized enough
to be the credibly neutral platform upon
which we wanted to trade. So
>> that's that's true. That's true. Yeah.
So you actually delved this in much
deeper than
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, I went deep on this one.
[laughter] Yeah.
>> Than I have
>> um let me ask you about YZI Labs used to
be called Binance Labs. It's a core
investment vehicle for you.
>> Um what is the core thesis these days?
Because I've seen that they've it used
to be mostly crypto or all crypto.
>> Now I'm seeing some AI some biotech
stuff too.
>> What are you guys doing there at YZI
Labs?
>> Yeah. So um yeah. Yeah. So I give a
rough guideline say look 70% crypto 20%
AI 10% biotech roughly. So I think all
three are large um sectors that will
continue to grow tremendously and all
three have so so much more new
innovations to be to be to be to be
discovered to be done to be built uh
that can have tremendous positive impact
in uh on our civilization basically. So
um uh easy labs uh uh philosophy I want
them to invest for impact and not
necessarily financial returns. Um they
are sometimes sometimes they they may
diverge. Um I'll give you an extreme
example right let's say we invest a
billion dollars into a uh drug research
company that cures say common disease
like cancer
>> and the the cure is very cheap uh and
the company may not make any money uh
but it will cure like you know a million
10 million 100 million people. I'll be
very happy to lose that one billion a
couple billion dollar investment. It
will make me super happy, right? Because
we we have the impact.
>> Well, and it's also like a smaller
principal investment. I guess it's more
the loss of it being a $1 billion gain,
right? Like
>> so yeah, funding it at the low at the
early stage is interesting for that
reason.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So yeah, so easy funds like look
for very early stage uh projects like
that that that are many of them are a
bit crazy. So they're very high failure
rates uh that we expect. But um we also
have uh I think we invest in some really
good projects. Um and
>> are there any that stand out right now
or I don't know recently in a new batch
or something that's been around that
like is really exciting you want to
promote like a portfolio company?
>> Well, there's a bunch of crypto
companies which I would not actually
talk about because I don't want to be
seen as promoting them specifically many
of them have tokens.
>> Yeah.
>> Um this there's artificial womb company
that we invested in. So now you have a
you can have a kid in your machine,
>> right? So you uh this frees the ladies
from the pregnancy process and then you
actually frees the guys from like know
getting attack well no [laughter]
begging a woman
>> an artificial womb.
>> Yeah. So it's I think they actually went
to the second trimester testing in rats.
So I think they're probably 5 10 years
away from humans.
>> Is this like growing humans like for
space travel for example?
>> Potentially like the different use cases
are huge right. So like well this is
going to be like the metrics if humans
are farmed.
>> Yeah. Well, that's what I'm [laughter]
I I gave more a charitable one. You
know, we actually we got to set up a new
civilization light years away and so we
just send the ship for a thousand years
and eventually it just births humans
there. I don't know. I'm making that up.
>> Pretty good sci-fi concept though. So
make
>> when you say when I say humans are
farmed like people can understand both
positive and negative impact of it which
I understand the technology could have.
U but but anyways it's a technology that
can help many many people. Um, and then
there's a recent another one that like
uses like a uses a pla not a plastic
like a 3D printed like a styrofoam that
puts in your knee cartilage and your
cartilage grow around it. So it causes
more growth of your knee cartilage.
>> Oh wow.
>> Many old people have knee problems.
Right. Uh so my
>> you don't have to be that old to have a
knee problem. I'm telling you right now.
>> Exactly. So uh so like no stuff like
that. Uh and uh this one is also quite
early. They haven't quite started. U I
I'm not I forgot the stage. they they
might just be starting the next clinical
trial on humans. Uh so stuff like that
and we investing a bunch of AI robotics
um as well. Um but you know um it's
actually the biotech companies that gets
me really excited. Um uh they just no
they just it's just very tangible like
one day you will help many many people
right where AI robots
>> we all know it's going to be big but
it's
>> it's cool. Yeah. But
>> yeah it's not like you just solved you
know everybody's knee problem. Exactly.
That's much more tangible.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So there's a psychological
like reward for those biotech
investments. Um yeah, so
>> I love that. Um let's talk about AI. Um
you guys are investing in AI. Um we're
building we have a we're an AI data
center company also in addition to
crypto.
>> Um everyone's using AI. I've got a bunch
of I asked the employees of Galaxy to
submit some questions. One that everyone
wanted me to ask was what is your
favorite LLM for you to use personally
right now? Like you know and we I switch
between them. You know, there's ups and
down, but right now, what what do you
like? Which phone app of AI are you
super excited about?
>> I have almost all of them installed. Um,
I subscribe to all of them. Um, and u uh
uh I use different ones for different
things. Um, well, OpenAI is the first
one you install, right? So, like they're
the oldest cl uh open uh uh anthrop uh
cloud is uh much better for coding, I
find like so but I don't write much
code, but it's still pretty good for
answering questions. I also find like
the different AI companies sometimes
they're not available in different
countries. I travel a lot. Is that true?
Interesting. So I travel a lot. So you
you travel you travel to some countries
one AI company is not available.
>> You just open the app and it's like
sorry I can't
>> servicing this country. I'm like I just
I'm just wait here for three three days.
But then you know you you go to the you
go to the next one. Uh and there there's
also some geopolitical tension as well.
Like for example when I know travel to
Hong Kong
>> Yeah.
>> Um none of the US AI companies work. So
then you use Deep Seek, Kimi, a bunch of
the Chinese guys. Yeah.
>> Um I'm not political. I'm like look, I
just use whatever is working on my
>> have to ask this question real quick.
Yeah. Can someone answer it, please?
>> Yeah. But overall though, I do I
generally find the US um uh uh um uh
lang large large language models to be
much more precise and much more
accurate. Uh whereas the Chinese open
source ones are very good as well, but
they are not as comprehensive sometime.
>> Yeah. Deep Seek um Kimmy I've used some
of these at home myself. Um
>> do you think well since you mentioned
the geopolitical aspect I think this is
very interesting. There's a great essay
many people have theorized but AI 2027.
Have you read that essay? It's really
good. I'll I'll share it with you after.
>> I got I got
>> well it's sort of like a you know from
from 25 to 207 what might happen and
then eventually it becomes a choose your
own adventure like accelerationist or
safety. Yeah. Um and but I you know one
of the big stories clearly of AI saw
China's announced some 200 plus billion
state investment in data center growth
obviously we have enormous private
mostly private but I think plenty of
public like support of data center
growth and capex spending here in the US
like is this is it going to turn into
like a you know cold war style AI arms
race like should it is it is it already
happening like
>> I okay u again I'm not expert on this
area um um but I actually do think that
it's gonna it's definitely going to be a
race uh every um um especially with
what's happening recently um I mean I
like it doesn't take two brand sales to
figure out China's definitely working on
their own chip right so um China
definitely is working on their own data
centers and both both countries right so
um US definitely trying to work on it
manufacturing
um and uh so it's it's a it's a race um
but racing competition is can be healthy
uh you actually promotes uh actually
increases the speed of growth but I
think on on AI we got to be a little bit
careful with the speed of growth um
because um AI is so powerful um that it
can be dangerous it can be very
dangerous so um uh right now many people
are looking at crypto regulations very
few people talk about AI regulations uh
what can you do not do with AI and
crypto regulations actually much simpler
u it's like it's just like a record
>> right you're just dealing with money
basically uh there's not a whole lot
more well there's KYC AML,
>> but it's all that same money stuff.
Basically, it's just new technology.
>> But AI can do so much more. AI can hack
your computer. Uh can uh figure out how
to build a nuclear bomb. Uh AI can do so
many different things. You can you can
program robots. Uh you can program nano
nanobots. Uh you can fly like flying
nanobots. Like what can you do and
cannot do with that? Um they can well
they obviously can can program drones um
etc. So there's so much application for
AI but I don't think anyone's really
thinking about well in a in a deep way
in a comprehensive way on how to
regulate AI. I say that but when I
actually think about that problem I
don't know how to do it. Yeah. It's so
it's such a hard problem
>> because you want to promote the growth
and innovation too. It's not just like
because we we have seen some proposals I
know in the US probably everywhere I
would assume. you know, there's a small
but rising populist backlash of like no
more data centers even, not just make
the AI safe, but like build less AI that
they're not that's not winning out at
the moment, but I haven't seen anything
more nuanced than that yet to your
point.
>> Typically, the the first versions of
regulations or what people say is like
too binary.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Yeah. We can regulate the industry
by killing it,
>> right?
>> Um that's not regulating, that's just
killing. Regula regulating the industry
means that you want to promote use of
it. Otherwise, you don't need to
regulate it, just kill it. Yeah,
>> that's that's that that's not
regulating, right? So, um um yeah, so
but it's just so hard to regulate AI. Uh
and many people are not thinking or
talking about it deeply. But when you
think about this problem, it's actually
very important for our civilization. Uh
AI, crypto, no matter what it does, it
doesn't have the power to extinguish our
civilization. Um it's very powerful.
It's like there's a lot of money
involved like you know it's it's it's a
great industry but um it helps global
commerce it grows our economy etc but it
it doesn't but AI has the power to
extinguish our our civilization if we're
not we don't use it carefully so u uh
yeah so but anyway um that's just me
ranting
>> yeah no I [laughter] appreciate it
that's what I wanted to hear you know we
I think one of my favorite things to
have you built anything personally at
home with claw code or whatever that
like you most people are tinkering with
something it's one of our favorite
questions to ask like over a Frank, what
are you building with AI?
>> Um, I tried to I but very
unsuccessfully. I tried open claw. Um,
>> uh, I installed it on my on one of my
unused Macs. Uh, and then I tried to get
it to uh, uh, to download my Gmail,
which it very easily connected to. Um,
and I try to get it to filter my email.
I get so much junk mail.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah.
>> Right. I get so much junk mail to the
point I don't use email.
>> No, me too. It's bad.
>> I just don't use don't use email. And
but I thought like he has this Gmail
skill. So like download see what it can
do plug that in got a Gmail API key put
it in uh I but it was so careful it was
so it was so it was so resistant to
deleting emails for for me I'm like oh
remove all the junk and only only show
me like you know the the emails emails
that are important but every like like I
would say probably 30% 40% of my emails
are requesting for some kind of uh
meeting with me
>> right
>> they're like well this guy's requesting
an email meeting with me like there's
all this meeting request. He thinks it's
important.
>> Right.
>> Right. I'm like
>> a lot of that's junk as well in your
mind. Yeah. It's just spam inbound.
>> I'm like 99% of that is like just junk
from people I don't know. Right. I'm not
going to accept those meetings. But so
like AI I tried it. It just doesn't do
what I what I need to do.
>> Interesting. Very interesting. Um let's
talk about um quantum a little bit.
Another thing I did a a presentation
earlier
>> to an investment bank about Bitcoin and
quantum and the mitigation paths. Are
you worried about quantum as a threat to
Bitcoin? No. Um uh I'm actually not
worried about it at all. Um I think
number one is um the more compute power
we have the better. Um they are already
quantum resistant uh encryption
algorithms. So all we need to do
conceptually very simple all we need to
do is upgrade the change the encryption
algorithm. Um but for a decentralized
know technology like Bitcoin and with so
many users all around different parts of
the world the coordination is difficult.
Um and there's also the Satoshi bitcoins
that you know uh that what do we need to
do etc. But overall, I'm not I'm not
worried about it. Um I also think that I
have a sneaky suspicion that know Google
says 2029.
>> Yeah.
>> Um it'd be very Yeah, I mean I'm I
appreciate that. No, they give they give
such
>> some urgency.
>> Some urgency and some some the early
notice. Um I don't know what's going on
in like what do they have? Maybe they
can already crack Bitcoin. They they
don't. And if that's the case, I'd be
super appreciative that the fact that
they don't
>> they don't. Yeah.
>> Um but more likely I think there might
be a little bit of a PR angle to that.
Like look, if you're a quantum
researcher, you want more attention uh
for for for quantum
>> and you might not put out a estimate
that's relatively aggressive like say 20
like you said 2035. Nobody was going to
read that article. Yeah.
>> Yeah. You said that's true. Right.
>> And I think actually under um testing
the one of the main Google um authors of
that paper, Craig Gibney, a longtime
quantum researcher said really he thinks
it's about a 10% chance by 2029.
>> Yeah. So Right. But I appreciate like
that that's an engineering est estimate.
>> Right. Right. [laughter] Right. And
honestly to be clear like I think
they've been getting pulled forward like
that that Google paper did describe a
substantial improvement. Yes.
>> In the math and therefore reduction in
the number of cubits required. So
>> so but regardless the day is going to
come. Yeah.
>> And then Bitcoin is going to have to
upgrade.
>> Um so um the ecliptical um encryption is
going to have to upgrade.
>> Yes. So uh but we and we as a community
need to somehow coordinate it. Um so
that's a task on us. Um
>> there's some early work happening but I
would say it's early and you know how
decentralized Bitcoin is like you know
Ethereum Foundation released a whole
road map. Well great like there's no
such group in Bitcoin to do that.
[laughter]
>> Um but I I'm seeing some green shoots of
activity I would say.
>> But I think when the urgency gets
stronger a few a number of key groups
will get together and there will still
be a lot of debates. There may even be
many forks of Bitcoin, but eventually
we'll we'll get there.
>> Yeah, I think about the risk of uh well,
we've Bitcoiners have lived through many
forks before, right?
>> Bitcoin Gold, Bitcoin Diamond, Bitcoin
Cash, Bitcoin, whatever. Tell me about
it.
>> It's funny that that doesn't happen as
much anymore, but that used to be like a
a major theme of Bitcoin for like
probably like three years, maybe like
2016 to like 2018. So many forks, right?
No, it was more like um it was more like
No, it was more like No, August 20
August 2017 was the first BCH fork.
>> BCH but there were there were some
others before.
>> So after the BCH fork
>> then it was the
>> uh Binance is the first exchange to say
we're going to support both forks uh
because otherwise the user have to
download the Bitcoin from the exchange
uh install both wallets and figure out
which one's SIG which one's uh not which
one's like you know this and to download
the entire Bitcoin blockchain takes like
three or four days back then. um they
have to go through all that work. Um so
Binance was the first exchange. I gave
this idea say look why don't we handle
this for users because we have a big
wallet and u we just give users the BCH
that they're supposed to get and then
we're done and then we list BCH and
people can trade.
>> Very few people exchange I did a study
back then um when I worked at Fidelity
about um what how they all the exchanges
handled the BCH fork. Many did nothing.
They technically had the keys, but they
didn't give you the BCH. Coinbase didn't
give you the BCH or let it to trade, I
think, until like December. Some I think
um maybe it was Bitfinex, they had pers
um also to to see where it would trade
in the future, which is actually a
really important thing if a forks had to
happen. But yes, I remember Binance was
one that said we'll just we're going to
give it to you.
>> Yeah.
>> Some I think sold it and gave you the
Bitcoin proceeds. Yeah.
>> Very strange.
>> But the but the counter effect was so
that helped a lot of you that helped a
lot of users. But the counter effect is
now then after that people saw that
Binance have Binance supports Bitcoin
forks and because we want to give use of
the benefits. So then there was like
Bitcoin gold, Bitcoin diamond, Bitcoin
and then most all of them are useless.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Right. But uh but all of them have some
value when they first fork uh and so um
so we were the exchange was forced to
support quite a number of them and then
so and after a while we said okay we're
going to have to stop. So like there was
like a I would say probably a three six
months period there was a lot of forks
and we stopped supporting them.
>> That was that was that
>> that was the the Bitcoin forks era was
exciting. Um so just back on the quantum
thing you mentioned this. So assuming we
get the tech to the the new cryptography
and Bitcoiners decide to add it and all
that part of it is solved. Should
Bitcoiners or Bitcoin do something with
Satoshi's coins or not? There's my
understanding is there's there's kind of
three options. you could do nothing and
effectively it's a bounty and the
downside obviously is that you likely
get the coins one day swept by an indie
that creates sell pressure
>> but the sell pressure does redistribute
them ultimately to the community so like
there's there's a minor upside there I
would say potentially long-term upside
versus short-term downside there's one
that says I don't know some version of
freeze and seize either to one day give
him back if he can you know show up with
a passport that says Satoshi or whatever
I know that's tricky since the only
proof we actually would have would be
cryptographic proof and that will have
been broken and then there's some sort
of middle ground idea which is like you
know slow the spending or something
should what do you think I mean and
knowing that you you know I'm not sure
where I stand on this but
>> I think the first option is definitely
bad uh we we should do something with it
um but I I would actually propose a
different solution um uh I think we
should say look uh once we we know we're
going to fork Bitcoin we should I would
I would put a fourth option on the table
say look as a community why don't we
give the uh why don't we give a timeline
say within 6 months or 12 months
>> uh if those coins don't move then we're
going to lock them
>> right so the on the new protocol those
those on the new protocol there will be
like only 20 million coins because um
we're just going to lock them
>> take away a million coins
>> just take away those million coins um
those addresses will be frozen uh on the
mirrored one those address will be
frozen I I would say let's give him a
year right if he uh if he doesn't do
that in a year um I think um then you
know we give him time um he may be alive
may not be alive he may he may even not
be a person who knows right
>> all right so u u but if we uh uh but if
we don't do anything with it then we we
basically giving to somebody who's going
to hack it the first guy who runs the e
quantum to crack it eventually that will
happen uh and that's not a good way to
distribute uh in my opinion um and and
it's slow so I that's what I would do uh
that was that's what I would suggest I
think at the end is what we do should up
to a community vote. Um, and I don't
know how like, you know, we probably
have to signal with a Bitcoin flag.
>> Yeah. In Bitcoin, the votes are usually
like minor flagging.
>> Yeah. The minor flag.
>> You could run nodes that support UASF
potentially, but that can be civil
attack. But yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> It's a tricky question. I I don't think
there's frankly any good answer to the
question, unfortunately.
>> No. No. I do think that uh if he doesn't
do anything with it uh we uh I my
recommendation would be well the new
protocol should be freezing like those
will be taken out of circulation.
>> Got it.
>> Yeah.
>> Um just two questions here to wrap up
that are sort of really quite
open-ended.
>> What is something in the last year that
you've changed your mind on
>> you know last year or two?
>> Oh that's this is a pretty simple one.
Yeah.
>> RWAS I was pretty skeptical like say a
year or a year and a half ago. I thought
like you know who's going to like I'm
not sure if anyone's going to trade this
stuff. I'm not sure if it's going to
take off but the speed is taking off
actually caught me by surprise.
>> Um so I think um and like you know um
stable coins, oil futures um AI stocks
um so they have very good uptake in the
crypto community. Um that means that the
demand is there um so that means that
many people in the world wanted to
access those things and they didn't have
access. So um um so that caught me by
surprise. Uh so I was no 10 years ago it
was stable coins but stable coins I got
over that quite quite a bit earlier.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Um last question CZ
>> you founded Binance in 2017 right?
What's something that's as obvious to
you today or that you are convicted in
today that you was obvious to you then
and that you were convicted in then?
Something that's held true to you
>> the whole time? Um
>> uh hold on. Let me ask uh
you mean but from a business opportunity
perspective or a belief perspective?
>> Yeah,
>> I would say a belief a belief
perspective. When you founded Binance,
you had great conviction in this thing
and today you have the same or even
stronger conviction. Can be an idea,
concept.
>> Okay. Okay. That's simple. I mean crypto
is not going away. Crypto is going to be
a big industry. Um so uh that hasn't
changed. Um so that that belief has now
like only got much much much stronger.
Um so uh that's yeah it's I don't know
how to explain it in simple terms. It's
just gonna get bigger. Um there's no way
for it to get smaller actually. Uh yeah
so the prices will fluctuate.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh of individual coins but um the
industry is going to grow. Um right now
you know like quite a lot of hot money
went to AI know they're chasing all the
AI stocks. Fantastic. Well guess what
people are trading AI stocks using
crypto now. Um the AI is actually
contributing to crypto's trading volume.
Um that may or may not help crypto
itself. some of the crypto itself but um
it's now the people are using blockchain
to access those things um and also uh AI
today as hot as it is today they don't
transact for us yet um so now they can
find the cheapest ticket for us but we
still have to pay for that ticket
ourselves
>> agentic trading and payments and stuff
you're thinking
>> they will come they will come in a
matter of month uh not years I think
>> and they use crypto
>> they will use crypto um uh imagine like
today if you launch that thing uh or you
have you have an agent that can buy your
tickets or trade for you or um um do
whatever you can integrate payment
system country by country or you can say
we're going to turn on crypto um and uh
and also for uh many of the current
payment system don't work with AI um the
AI can't swipe your visa card you can
probably fill a form but whenever
there's a 2FA whenever like how can the
KYC show your passport you just can't do
do those things whereas with blockchain
it's it's it's it's API driven right so
um it's much easier for AI to So, um,
while AI is great, AI is a tool for you
to get stuff done, AI still need to
spend money. AI still need to transact.
Guess what? They're going to use the
blockchain. Well, they're going to use a
better, uh, we still need a good, we
still need to continually upgrade the
the current financial system. So, um,
the financial system not going away like
know when we had blockchain, internet
didn't go away. When we have AI,
blockchain and internet is not going to
go away. Um, so, uh, all three are big
big technologies. Uh so I think people
many people ask me like no are you
worried that you know all the money is
going to AI? No. Uh yes some money went
uh but that's that's okay. Uh there's
enough money around and we're dealing
with money industry. Even the money that
went there still flows on the
blockchain.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Increasingly. Well thank you so much CZ
founder of Binance for coming on Galaxy
Brains.
>> Oh thank you for having me. Yeah.
>> Thank you for listening to Galaxy Brains
the weekly podcast from Galaxy Research.
I'm Alex Thorne head of firmwide
research at Galaxy. Follow me on X at
Intangible Coins. Follow Galaxy Research
on Xgxy
Research. Read our written reports at
galaxy.com/ressearch.
And don't forget if you like Galaxy
brands to like and subscribe on your
favorite podcast platforms like YouTube,
Spotify, Apple Podcasts, and more. We'll
see you next time.